la guerre en ukraine l'a conduit à
devoir réécrire complètement sa campagne
et le candidat qu'il voulait être
le projet que je vous présente
aujourd'hui est aussi évidemment ancré
dans le moment qui est le nôtre
c'est-à-dire celui du retour du tragique
dans l'histoire nous arrivons à un
moment où le sujet n'est plus de gérer
simplement le quotidien mais de prendre
des choix parfois historiques profonds
et en rupture
ce n'est évidemment pas un hasard s'il a
décidé de commencer cette conférence de
presse par ses sujets extrêmement
extrêmement lourd de sens il a insisté
sur le fait qu'il avait été un président
qui gérer les crises et qu'il allait
être un président s'il était reconduit
qu'ils allaient continuer à endosser ces
crises mondiales et qui était évidemment
capable de le faire je pense que devant
les peurs qui monte face à ce retour du
tragique à la guerre aux crises au
sentiment de dépossession qui
aujourd'hui habitent nos sociétés il
nous faut répondre par une ambition
lucide une volonté d'engagement
instruite par justement cette expérience
commune des dernières crises là on
retombe dans le fait d'élire de façon
très rationnelle et pragmatique
quelqu'un qui est capable d'être aux
manettes d'un état à un moment inédit de
son histoire c'est une question à la fav
de posture de légitimité c'est tout
l'objet du projet que je veux
aujourd'hui vous soumettre une forme
d'optimisme de la volonté avec je le
crois une crédibilité liés aux cinq
dernières années je tâche de faire ce
que je dis et j'essaie de dire à chaque
fois ce que je fais j'avais promis de
baisser le chômage malgré les crises
nous l'avons fait j'avais pris
l'engagement de baisser les impôts
malgré les crises nous l'avons fait
j'avais dit que nous réduirions nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
l'avons fait deux fois plus vite
qu'auparavant -12% durant ce quinquennat
face à des engagements que j'avais pris
devant plusieurs d'entre vous et devant
nos compatriotes il ya cinq ans l'action
a été au rendez vous et les résultats
sont ici présents ce qui est à ce qui
est très vrai je trouve c'est qu'il ya
un décalage
entre la parole du président en surplomb
qui s'exprime sur des thématiques
extrêmement grave extrêmement lourde de
sens il a vraiment commencé sur les
sujets de protection des français et en
même temps ce président qui a
l'obligation de descendre dans le
quotidien des français de descendre dans
l'arène et je pense que c'est ce
décalage qui est en effet extrêmement
complexe à gérer et il a oscillé entre
les deux tout au long finalement de
cette conférence de presse et je
souhaite aussi que nous renforcions nos
capacités à nous défendre face aux
nouveaux risques prix de l'électricité
doivent faire l'objet d'une réforme et
nous porterons ce sujet par exemple la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
les crises que nous vivons les
transitions les nouvelles formes de
guerre le plein emploi la réforme des
retraites fait un programme qui
quelles que soient les temps et parce
que nous sommes sûrs d'avoir à nouveau
affronter des crises et des grands
bouleversements assume aussi de porter
une ambition forte le coeur de sa
campagne était au départ écrit sur la
sortie de crise duco vide et donc sur un
discours très positif la guerre en
ukraine l'a conduit à devoir réécrire
complètement sa campagne et le candidat
qu'il voulait peut-être qui est en effet
extrêmement intéressant dans la façon
dont il a présenté à la fois les droits
que les citoyens étaient en droit
d'attendre dans ce nouveau quinquennat
et les devoirs qui devaient être les
leurs on doit avoir des règles et un
site encore davantage au retour à
l'emploi mais il faut pouvoir mieux
accompagner chacune et chacun
reconnaître cette dignité et les
demandes et une part de devoir oui il
faut un soutien monétaire mais il faut
en plus de ça reconnaître la dignité de
chacun demandé une part d'efforts pour
toutes celles et ceux qu'ils peuvent et
de devoirs et un accompagnement c'est le
retour d'une somme à l'afad pragmatisme
très fort et aussi d'autorité parce que
je tire aussi les enseignements qu'ils
n'avaient pas été compris je n'ai pas
réussi à porter la réforme des
institutions notre constitution que je
défends des parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'accord politique revenir sur des
échecs qui ont pu être ceux de son
quinquennat marquerait un décalage
beaucoup trop fort entre
le président omniprésent chef de guerre
et le candidat qui cherchent à rattraper
des échecs qui ont pu être les siens
donc en effet c'est une tonalité qu'il
n'adopte absolument pas à part peut-être
et en quelques mots sur la réforme des
retraites et en parlant de la réforme
des retraites je parle je crois l'une
des deux grandes réformes que je n'ai
pas pu mener à terme durant ce
quinquennat la pandémie ayant stoppé la
réforme qui avait été conduite en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
au début de l'année 2020 on n'a pas dans
cet exercice le même élan que lors des
meetings on n'a pas non plus la même
proximité que l'heure des interviews
mais là aussi on est finalement dans ce
qui correspond parfaitement à l'adn des
manuels macron il nous avait habitués à
ce qu'il appelait lui même la pensée
complexe et on a senti au long tout au
long de cette conférence de presse une
forme de en tout cas de lassitude peut
être d'un certain nombre de journalistes
devant la longueur de l'exercice mais ça
fait pour le coup totalement partie de
son adn et de ce à quoi il nous avait
habitués ce qui est en effet assez
intéressant ce sont les moments de
connivence qui crée avec les
journalistes on va en effet qu'il
n'attend pas les questions pour être à
leur écoute et pour commencer à
interagir avec eux beaucoup a été fait
je le disais mais
énormément nous reste à faire je le dis
avec beaucoup de clarté je pourrai
répondre à vos questions dites moi s'il
ya quelque chose qui n'est pas clair
non mais je
une idée je pense était aussi de créer
un peu de dynamisme dans un exercice
extrêmement long je vais maintenant
répondre à tout bloquer
emmanuel macron a montré tout au long de
son quinquennat qu'il avait pour le coup
une relation extrêmement fluctuante avec
avec les médias évidemment il est dans
une configuration qui lui demande de
créer une forme à la fin de complicité
de proximité et des changes je dirais
que c'était un exercice qui était
extrêmement des risques extrêmement
formaté nous avait habitués à des
pirouettes beaucoup plus spectaculaire
là on est dans quelque chose de très
maîtrisée qui forcément permet d'avoir
une vision beaucoup plus clair de son
programme petit ne permet pas de créer
le même élan pour 2017 ce sera sans
doute ce qu'il cherchera à faire lors de
son ultime du derby
[Musique]